if nero automato was about discovering
your humanity in a world devoid of life
near replicant is about a world
desperately fighting to preserve what
humanity it has left
and often failing to do so those you
fight for fight with
fight against and you the protagonists
all have a stake and responsibility in
this plight there's an ever-present
melancholy that hangs over the world of
near
and the more you fight on the more you
understand just how tragic human life
can be
it's tempting to wallow in sorrow but
once you've seen near republicans
conclusions in their entirety
you'll come to cherish its moments of
warmth as well
for better or worse near-applicant
preserves much of the original
experience from its 2010 release
based off the japanese version the story
characters scenarios and structure
remain intact
and this remaster includes some
significant gameplay and visual
improvements
in addition to an essential piece of new
story content that expands the original
narrative
this is an action rpg with slick combat
reminiscent of automata but it suffers
from the antiquated design philosophies
it adheres to
however near replicant is here to make
you feel something and does so in a
fashion very few games can pull off
series creator yokotaro has a penchant
for toying with player expectations
saying just enough to lead you on before
hitting you with the wild revelations
that leave you sinking in your seat
it was near strongest suit back in the
day and still is with this remaster
the game starts off in modern day tokyo
that's been destroyed and invaded by
ethereal creatures called shades then
thrusts you over a thousand years into a
future medieval civilization
that's barely scraping by both the
protagonist and his sister yonah are
almost
exactly as they were in that mysterious
intro seemingly unchanged by the passage
of time so right from the jump
questions start to fill your head and
the desire for answers grows
increasingly urgent as you press on
yona is gravely ill and the initial
motivation that pushes you through near
replicant
revolves around saving her but yonah is
only one part of a more complicated
world
you'll fall in love with characters like
kaine the foul-mouthed badass who wins
your heart over with her unapologetic
attitude and growth as a person
she also carries burdens you'll come to
understand over time
emile is the wholesome boy who remains
full of glee optimism
and unconditional love for his friends
despite the pain and trauma he harbors
and the floating talking book grimar
vice is a sassy wisecrack who wields the
magic and knowledge needed to save the
day
while also giving the team grief at
every step the way vice comes around
is nothing short of endearing book
how dare you i am grimoire vice
wielder of arcane nice then do not
abbreviate
my name you're an ass but you're right
in a broken and desolate world near
replicant finds a sense of life
energy and personality by leveraging a
strong dynamic between each of these
characters
and you as the protagonist from the
silly banter to the hype of intense
cutscenes
to the major emotional story events
their companionship
and distinct purpose are at the heart of
nir and what compels you as a player to
push through the grim
often overbearing realities of the
situations they're in
they're also backed by incredible
performances of the original cast
who reprised their roles however the act
of playing the game isn't always the
most exciting thing
while the combat has been revamped by
developer toy logic
bringing it closer to the style of
platinum game's effort in near automata
the overall structure of near replican's
open world is left untouched it's a slow
start that involves running errands here
and there
as you venture out into the world you're
frequently backtracking and returning to
a handful of locations
while fending off pesky shades and
repetition starts to settle in
you get to know the various locations
and the people that inhabit them
more intimately because of these back
and forth quests and it does make sense
in the story's context
but constant backtracking can wear down
your enthusiasm near replicant retains
some very basic level designs that
aren't exactly fitting for a modern
action rpg
as a result exploring and fighting
through the game's handful of
unimaginative areas
isn't all that thrilling the junk keeps
linear corridors the lost shrine series
of rooms and box sliding puzzles
and the arbitrary challenges of the
baron temple don't really hold up all
that well
even if some exciting and intense fights
lie within you will encounter some huge
imposing enemies
in major boss fights and it's an awesome
spectacle especially with seamless
transitions in perspective that spark a
bit of variety in the gameplay
experience
there is a turning point halfway through
where the action kicks up and the stakes
are more
dire while you're still trudging through
familiar locations the combat starts to
shine at this point
pushing the gameplay to match the thrill
and intensity of near applicant's story
stay out of my way he's mine
now in combat your ability to finesse
enemies using various blades parrying
and dodging mechanics in between combos
will keep you engaged
with vice by your side you have a slew
of magic spells to supplement your
prowess in battle you're a bit limited
in how many spells you can equip at a
time but finding the few that are useful
for your style
and executing them in tandem with your
melee skills it's satisfying
when it all comes together this revamped
combat system is silky smooth but for as
sweet as it might be
the enemy encounters haven't evolved
that much along with it as you grow
familiar with the different enemy types
and recognize simple boss patterns
combat can become a rather simple affair
it's great that this game which is a bit
hard to get a hold of nowadays has been
faithfully recreated
false and all but you can't overlook how
its dated aspects even by 2010 standards
can make for an antiquated experience
this means that as a whole
gameplay is more of a vehicle for
near-replicant story and
act of playing it puts some key
narrative themes into important context
this game tests your patience but the
payoff is immense
it's worth jumping through the necessary
hoops in order to see every aspect of
near replicant's various conclusions
you just wouldn't get the full picture
otherwise and the full picture
is wholly satisfying
here and now
[Music]
now the term endings is a bit of a
misnomer with regards to near
subsequent playthroughs help
recontextualize what you've seen before
replaying chunks of the game means the
series of events are familiar so the
additional context captures your
undivided attention
often leaving you questioning yourself
or experiencing a revelation
about a particular story beat you
initially didn't think much of at first
near replicant doesn't make you play the
entire game over again but it can wear
you down by the time you start your
third route
but like i said the reward is
unforgettable this reissue of near
replicant also contains a new
ending i won't get into details for
obvious spoiler reasons
but you'll experience shock and triumph
in this heart warming epilogue
and after its emotional jaw-dropping
moments it somehow makes the world of
near feel more
full for all of its impactful moments
near
isn't what it is without the tremendous
soundtrack by keichi okabe
and his team at monika
[Music]
the music of near replicant carries this
inexplicable sorrow
sometimes with a hint of triumph even
more so with the fresh arrangements in
this version of the game
the catchy melody you hear in multiple
variations through the northern plains
the seafront and the desert carries some
of the game's narrative weight
the character themes for a meal and
kaine are repeated throughout
and remixed in powerful fashion in a way
it becomes part of how you understand
who they are
and when i made certain connections
about the song of the ancients
that devil and popo is seeing i felt a
new sentimentality about the near
universe wash over me
automata is often and rightfully revered
for its soundtrack
and you can trace those beautiful sounds
back to the original game
it's one of the loveliest aspects of
near replicant to experience
and hear how this franchise ties
together i'm not gonna lie near
replicant made me ugly cry on several
occasions
kaine emil and vice will win your heart
with their earnest and endearing
personalities
making their tragic journey with you and
the tremendous story moments hit
hard despite some significant gameplay
enhancements the links you have to go to
to see the story all the way through
will be a test of your willpower but for
all of its antiquated designs retained
from the original version
it's worth the effort in the end thus
neoreplicant is essential for anyone who
has love for automata
and it's a special experience on its own
is
it's malfunctioning yeah this might be a
problem